now grace coming here tonight who are
you really most excited about meeting
emotions were high two years ago at
Canada's Walk of Fame
when Ryan rushed the stage to greet a
young girl named grace Bowen and her
hockey hero Olympian Haley recognizer
she introduced me to grace baller and
like a lot of people who met grace bone
I fell in love with baseball it's one of
the best tips she's giving me just
always be shown just over a year later
grace would lose her hard-fought battle
with osteosarcoma at the age of nine
today Cheryl sits down with her parents
Andrea and Greg how are you doing today
too much harder than the first year you
know you walk through the house and you
get a glimpse you hear a moment you feel
her presence and it's it's like getting
hit by a car after her passing Ryan sent
flowers and called the Bohn family home
what was it about grace that touched you
so much I mean I met her briefly that
day and she was very special I just saw
how what she was going through affected
everyone around her and how inspiring
she was for animals grace was kind of a
catalyst for me because I I had no idea
but I was about to step into to working
on on Deadpool which is a character his
cancer and something all these kids were
reaching out to me who had cancer you
know you start to see these guys when
you think about how lucky and how
privileged we are that you know I'm one
of the lucky people that like kids are
healthy
and well I want to do everything I can
to help people who are going through
this amidst his hectic schedule Ryan
personally reached out to sick kids and
flew himself to Toronto today to support
the organization what does it feel like
for you to have Ryan coming to do
something so special you know Ryan's a
movie star Ryan's famous but most of all
Ryan's a dad I heard the only thing on
your Rider was that you needed to be
home to tuck your kids in tonight yeah
that's about it yeah that's an alright
thing I think that is the best rider
I've ever heard in my life yeah I think
yeah yeah most showbiz people it's it's
hard drugs but for me it's uh yeah
that's it